Hello,
welcome to the U S S S where we drink vodka for
breakfast,
where we cuddle our pet bears in our backyards and where instead of taking
a morning shower, we jump in a frozen Lake.
I see.
So is anyone going to tell me how on earth we got here?
When did the history go so wrong?
What does the moon have to do with all this? Should I brush up on my Russian?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if Russia won the space race?
Remember those wild 1950s Russia,
formerly known as the Soviet union launched a satellite into space for the first
time followed by the launch of their first Astro dog. Laika.
Great start by the Russians,
but lost some points there for not bringing life back home safely.
The U S began to catch up with its own satellite Explorer. One.
They threw in the Apollo program and a big moon speech for good measure.
It's all or nothing. 1961.
The USSR sent the first man into space. Impressive.
The U S team sent their first man into space. Nice.
1963,
the first woman a Russian went to space beat that NASA
1968. Unbelievable. They're about to set foot on the moon.
Here goes one small step for man one giant leap for
Russia. Yep. You heard me.
I'm about to give you a history lesson,
a hypothetical history lesson in which Neil Armstrong.
Wasn't the first astronaut to walk on the moon.
Wouldn't have been too bad. If the USSR had one space race, right?
How much would things really change?
Well in the spirit of the cold war,
the nation that won the space race would control the earth.
And in this alternate timeline,
it was Russia who had the control button.
By the time Neil Armstrong stepped on the moon.
NASA's funds had started to dry up.
People just didn't see why they should be paying for some far-fetched space
exploration. Unlike the democratic United States,
socialist Soviet Russia wouldn't have stopped there.
They'd have had all the funds and the workforce,
not only to come back to the moon multiple times,
but also to establish a lunar base on it. Sure.
They'd have to boost their computing power.
Even if that meant stealing some of the American technology
for the United,
the Soviets landing on the moon would have been quite shocking. And from there,
it all could go in two ways,
the Americans would have to catch up and they'd have to do it fast.
And where would you go if the moon was already housing, communist,
Russians to Mars, of course,
the next big defining moment of the space race would have been landing on Mars.
It would most likely be an unmanned probe. At first,
maybe a satellite sent into the orbit of Mars.
The Russians would have been rushing to get the first man craft to the Martian
surface.
And the Americans would have had to try hard to beat their communist adversary.
By the end of the 1980s,
humanity might have put the first astronauts on the red planet,
but who would have been the first to plant a flag on its cold surface?
Whoever that would have been that country would have claimed the title of
leading outer space Explorer,
but it wouldn't have meant that in the case of Russia taking the lead,
that the us would have become a socialist state or that the whole world would
end up speaking Russian.
It probably didn't hurt to have a Russian English phrase book just in case.
There are only so many places you can send humans to explore relatively
safely.
The majority of outer space would be studied through unmanned probes.
The tight space race would have resulted in all technology developing at a much
faster rate. And by the 2020s,
we would be taking vacations on the moon and on Mars,
that is if things had taken a different turn after the first moon landing,
alternatively,
after the Russians had beaten the United States to landing on the lunar surface,
the U S could have admitted their loss and stepped back. I mean,
if the Americans hadn't become the first in space will,
why bother paying to be the second?
And as the Russians lost their primary challenger,
they could have lost interest in space, travel all together.
And in that case,
the alternative history wouldn't be much different than what it is today.
But while these two Titans were caught up in their contentious relationship,
they could have missed what some other countries were up to.
But that's a story or another.
What if.